حلقه اليوم وحلقه امس كمان راح ننهي اليوم
حلقتنا باحتفالات يوم التاسيس مجموعه ام
بي سي شاركت في الاحتفالات بطرح اغنيه من
انتاجها وغناء النجم ماجد المهندس بعنوان
1727 الاغنيه من كلمات خالد المريخي
والحان محمد وعنوانها يشير تاريخ تاسيس
الدوله السعوديه بالسلط الضوء في كلماتها
والكليب على تاريخ المملكه الراسخ الممتد
اكثر من ثلاثه قرون انا اترككم مع مقطع من
الاغنيه واعودوا القاكم الاحد ان شاء الله
في امان الله
يا نخله من دونها حادث
عرقك بلا رضوان
يحرسك ربي السعودي
يا ام المعزه والوفاء والكرامات
نخله من دونها حاجتي سيفين عرقك بالارض
[موسيقى]
يا ام المعزه والوفاء
والكرامات يا ام المعزه والوفاء والكرم
كل ما كبرتي يا بلادي تزيني
وانت كبيره اصلا من البدايه
[موسيقى]